this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is brought to you by patreon
if you want to suggest upcoming guests
for this show or submit questions for me
to ask them you can do all of that on
patreon plus it is the only place that
you can get the audio version of this
show and it's completely ad free so if
you'd like to support this somewhat
Niche but hopefully very informative and
fun content check out patreon.com
Charles Amazon hello everyone welcome to
another episode of video game voice
acting or voice acting 101 I haven't
decided yet I'm Alana this is my friend
Matthew Mercer Matt um who are you
exactly what are you doing here Ah
that's that's a very existential
question today well I'm still trying to
find answers yes I am I am an American
voice actor uh for video games cartoons
and whatever whatever else in between I
guess
um and I also do fun nerdy stuff on the
internet and that's kind of the quick
and dirty of it all but I'm also a huge
nerd so kind of gotta be right
you feel like that kind of hand in hand
yeah I mean like even if you've if you
come into this as and I know a number of
people have come to the industry from
the professional theater direction or
you know I know I'm on a series on
camera actor and then they start getting
into the video game process and the
development cycle and playing them and
going oh no I've I've already
pre-ordered this system and I have my
steam deck now that I have on my on the
volume and we're doing mocap and you're
like oh oh you you caught the bug you
thought you'd stay away we'll get you
every single time
um for anyone who's not familiar with
their work your list of credits is too
long it's too long you gotta stop
there's too many credits it's absurd but
uh yeah some of your favorites out
what's what are some of the favorite
characters that you've you've voiced
this is where it ends
let's see uh well I voice Cassidy uh in
OverWatch and OverWatch 2 that's one
that a lot of people are familiar with
the good old cowboy character you all
used to hearing around
um
let's see what I can talk about there's
a lot of fun stuff that's in the wings
under NDA that uh that's good we love a
working actor we're in support he's a
working actor it's perfect
um other things people might know me as
far as uh uh recent video games Persona
5 I voice
uh yusuke kitagawa the soft artist boy
I'm actually having to look at my
credits here because I'm trying to
remember what the hell there are too
many I
think
you love uh a Persona five uh it's uh
that's good it's coming out on Xbox very
soon too which is probably gonna be
pretty cool I think the first time that
Atlas has put any games in that series
on
um XBox which is super exciting you're
getting a whole new audience that's true
that's true oh other things people want
to know about uh the recent released
cyberpunk Edge Runners on Netflix voice
Falco the driver on that one very good
the good old southern boy uh blood of
Zeus on Netflix on Hermes
uh for anime fans out there I'm full
Garla on one piece as well as Levi and
Attack on Titan
and uh mostly mostly Andy projects then
it's mostly like little yes like not
quite IPS just like kind of little tiny
up and coming
projects and one that I'm really really
proud of is uh the legend of Vox Machina
on Amazon Prime it's based on our DND
game then I get to voice a number of
characters yeah how did that come about
that's nuts was that like an idea that
you had or did somebody approach you
about that uh well uh the the original
impetus for a critical role which for
those aren't familiar with uh me and a
bunch of other voice actor friends of
mine in the industry started playing d d
at home 10 years ago and I've been
playing Dandy since I was a little kid a
teenager at least and uh we had the
opportunity to start streaming it we
were like okay but no one's gonna watch
it it's four hours at a time of us just
sitting around a table making up stuff
and rolling Dice and we were very wrong
the most successful twitch Channel
uh I it is definitely the most
subscribed that's enough which is wild
yeah uh mind you we're dividing it
amongst a company of many many people
yeah but still I mean I kind of Imagine
That to be a thing when you when you
started out how impressive no not at all
I'm ever grateful and and pinching
myself that we have this the
opportunities that we have with this but
uh as it grew we tried pitching around
the idea of taking these stories from
our campaign that we played and turning
it into animated form in every place
that we pitched it out when I don't get
it
we went to Kickstarter and asked if our
community could support us in doing a
22-minute pilot for 750k which is a big
ask
and uh we ended up raising over 11
million dollars and funded an entire
season one and then once that happened a
lot of the people that we talked to the
first round started coming back around
going hey oh
and uh so yeah so the the folks that
were the the most
uh Pleasanton and willing to make it a
partnership as opposed to an ownership
you know scenario was was the Prime
video folks and so we they picked it up
for two seasons actually the first
season that was funded and then they
funded a second season with additional
episodes and then we just got greenlit
for a third season that we got to
announce recently I feel like the
coolest thing about critical role is
that it it still through all the time
even doing it and how much of like a big
company it's become is you all clearly
really enjoy what you're doing
and I feel like people really lose that
threat along the way and it's so it's
you know again as big as you are it's
really nice to see everybody succeeding
because you're all just having a good
time and it's really Positive Vibes and
it's like always so engaging and it's
hard not to root for you all thank you
and I it's it's not easy like you know
on on this scale trust me every step of
the way that's our biggest fear because
as you said like there are so many
examples of something that started
genuine and joyful and have it grow to
the point where it squeezes all that joy
out and so every step we take we're all
checking in with each other we're
meticulous and ensuring that we're all
on the same page we carve out as much
time as we can to spend together and
when we do play at that table like
that's our sacred time of the week where
we do get a chance to just you know shed
the rest of the responsibilities and
worries of the world and just be friends
together for the next four hours
so it's it's not easy the world
definitely wants you to wants you to
squeeze all the joy out of the things
that become successful in the mirror we
are doing our damnedest at every turn to
give it the finger is that very nice is
that your first foray into a more
production side of things working on the
Animated Series
uh for for animation yes I worked for a
number of years in a video game industry
on the dev side and that kind of helped
me yeah I understand funnily enough I
worked for a little bit at Sony Santa
Monica Studio where you know where
I have no idea that's really cool I
worked as a the QA manager for a short
time on the at the end of God of War one
and the development of God of War II
under Corey yeah of course uh back when
he was just a producer wasn't he
director on God of War II but he
eventually became director yeah yeah
that's wild I had no idea
there you go yes so that was how
different is all of that now like if
that's the experience you've had of
going from QA manager in Game Dev to I
guess full-time voice actor to then
critical role being this huge company
that now has an animated show like do
you feel like all of the different Paths
of of the work that you do inform the
others or did they sometimes detract
I don't think they detract at all if
anything it helps me appreciate the
scale of effort and energy that goes
into the creation of something I get a
chance to work on you know a video game
for a voice actor is a very solitary
experience often and you you know
between the occasional writer and
producer and of course the director
you're working with
that's your only really know only real
knowledge of what goes into this project
coming from game development into voice
over I understand how many people are
putting their lives into this you know
everything from the the rigors and
texture artists to the sound designers
to the level designers to even the low
end QA folks that don't get anywhere
near the attention and love that they
should for how intrinsically important
they are to this industry I I'm thankful
that I have that perspective so that I
can one know that I'm just one piece of
the tapestry that makes the game great
not to undersell the talent that we do
as voice actors but I also want to
always remind myself that many other
people deserve a lot of attention and
and love for the final product of these
games and then also now going into
animation
being eager and excited to learn and
meet and engage with all the different
departments that end up bringing this
series together and making sure they
feel appreciated and
yeah I just I don't know I'm I'm very
thankful that all the things that I grew
up and working towards thinking I was
going to do on the production side of
things wanting to be an animator wanting
to be in game design and eventually just
going into voiceover full time I now
have an opportunity to be ten gentle to
that yeah and get to know people who do
these things that I once wanted to do
and let them know that they're
appreciated and they're doing a great
job to learn from them which is always
the best learning from people who are
good at stuff great time highly
recommend nothing makes me happier than
realizing I'm surrounded by more
talented people in this department that
I'm that I'm in it's it's great yeah I I
definitely very much stand by if I feel
like I know more than other people in
the room that I need to get out of the
room and get in a different room for
sure there's a better line from people
um so this is a question back to voice
acting specifically that I I think I've
only asked a couple of people and
there's a significant variation in
answers actually what form of voice
acting do you find to be the most
challenge changing or are there
different challenges like say video game
voice acting versus animation voice
acting versus anime voice acting because
that's certainly a different style too
like is there anything that stands out
as the hottest or what are some of the
differences between the mediums
that's a good question um
I wrote it myself you're welcome uh for
me they're all they all have overlap but
each has its own unique kind of skill
set that you learn as you go into those
fields anime definitely is a very
technical process because not only you
having to be present and mindful of the
script and the dialogue and be present
in the scene and trying their best to
live and perform honestly as to what the
the animation already calls for you but
you're having to take all that
that raw emotion and that place that
you're existing in your imagination and
bring that authentic performance while
fitting it into this already rigid box
that's been built and has no more room
to expand or anything so it's
you're having to match timing and beats
of Animation uh rapidly so it's it's
kind of learning how to split your mind
into two different parts one is the
authentic performer and the other one's
kind of like a
I don't know a program running in the
background that's keeping tabs on timing
in beats and you know the the
limitations of your recording space per
line so I find that people who have a
music background or at least have
appreciation for music tend to fit well
into anime because you have that sense
of timing huh yeah I wouldn't have
guessed I wonder if that's a teachable
thing like do you think that that's
something that you just learn over time
or is there a specific thing that you
could like teach someone if they want to
get into anime voice acting specifically
I think you can teach it I I think I
think people naturally have a knack for
it if they have like a musical
background or at least you know uh have
have toyed in those spaces but I think
it's very much teachable it is a rhythm
it's learning and getting a natural
instinct for Pace listening to a piece
of Japanese dialogue listening to the
inflections not being married to it
finding finding your own natural uh you
know space and that delivery but also
knowing that's roughly two and a half
seconds so this is about a second and
second point two that I have to work
with and then just practicing on your
own a lot of it's just recording
listening back looking at the timing and
pace of it and then eventually you just
instinctually begin to feel that that
length process so then how does that
compare to something like video games
where I imagine a lot of the time you
are recording before animation is done
or you're doing mocap yeah yeah well for
for performance capture it's definitely
uh closer to theater or on camera work
um I would say it's closer to theater to
be honest because one you don't have the
crutch of costumes and decorated set
pieces and lighting to get you into the
mood plus you have to like find this
this
Middle Ground between very grounded real
cinematic performances that are just
slightly enhanced not so much where it
becomes cartoony but just enough that
the capture uh equipment and the
animations can pick up the nuances a lot
of on-camera actors that go into
performance capture that don't have a
theater background
sometimes they end up having replay
having to replace them afterwards
they're too muted they're too used to
letting everything live in just like
this part of their face micro
expressions and that might be changing
now that the technology is catching up
with the details and nuances but there
have been many projects for me or other
friends have been brought into her place
really high profile performers because
just the data capture wasn't getting
anything it makes sense I read a study
not that long ago that said that the
number one thing that humans identify as
bad acting even if it's somebody who has
no experience with acting is too many
facial expressions and I think that's an
interesting one because a lot of people
who get into acting which I'm sure I've
done before too is you think that to act
you must do everything with you I'm mad
so I'm doing this but crying is a very
interesting one right like if you see
often a man or a father figure cry on
camera what they usually conveying if
they're a very good actor is a man
trying not to cry that's the thing that
tuxia hot is like oh it's not somebody's
sobbing it's the somebody trying not to
and trying to hold it back that makes
you go oh my God but I think that as
people who aren't trained actors you're
just like I just gotta move my face a
lot so then you translate the lack of
movement that probably uh
very experienced actors have onto a
video game and then it just doesn't show
anything at all and that's that's
definitely an interesting problem that
would be hard to prepare people for yeah
but that's not always the case like I
said there are a lot of performers who
are multi uh trained and and end up
finding a really wonderful place to play
in that volume and so that's that's kind
of a unique mixture of theater on camera
and and voice over experience as well
knowing projection and vocal exercise
um and then uh that's just for
performance capture video games also
often there's a very solitary experience
you know unlike uh animation which a lot
of freely animation you get to record in
the room with other actors and everyone
gets to play off of your performances
and energy and kind of feels like a like
a writer's room as much as it is a
performance in some projects for a lot
of video game projects that aren't mocap
you're sitting there staring at an Excel
document with hundreds of lines on it
and you're just
given as much context as the Director
can fit with the time they have allotted
for you to record a certain number of
lines they need in that four hour
session you don't even get the whole
script
no just little chunks and so there's
there's definitely a trust exercise
between you and the director and any of
the producers that are on the line to
cut through
all of the context and try and translate
the the important emotional beats that
you as a performer can take in and bring
that authenticity to the performance and
it once again helps honestly to be a
nerd because you have the context for
the genre video game you kind of know
the level of energy and the type of
performance that are being looked for
you know if you're doing like a a GTA or
a more modern natural cinematic grounded
performance you know to keep it the kind
of casual breaths taking you know odd
beats and running lines together and you
know thought you know stumbles and
things that keep it in that grounded
cinematic feel but if it's you know a
shadow of War type game where it's all
theatrical fantasy everything has a
certain performance Pace to it and there
must be a grandioseness to what you
present so like you know knowing the
genres
directed video game yeah
and it shows it's very theatrical which
is really who he is as a man
he is a very wonderfully theatrical
individual
um but yeah like it's so knowing the
genres helps a lot in that circumstance
um but you are by yourself and so the
people that are really really good voice
actors for video games are the ones that
know how to tap into that imagination to
take in minimal Direction and then make
strong honest choices based on the the
little tidbits the the crumbs of context
they can get and make it feel real make
it feel honest and once again you're
just working with your voice you can't
you can't rely on micro Expressions on
the face so it's it's grounded
with a slight Goose to it you know where
someone can can show in their face and
their eyebrows for a very close-up tight
camera shot in the film
oh God we have to run and have a
completely monotone but in voiceover you
have to give it that little bit of edge
like
oh God we have to run wow still sounds
grounded but it's just a slight Goose I
can't do that I've done a little bit of
a video game voice acting haven't
figured that out yet
um I believe I'll keep it in mind that
that's the thing I need to do better but
I'm definitely not good at it like I
just go I don't know I guess this
I I hear it that's also part of it too
true but I hear choices a lot you know
people talk about make a choice and I
feel like that is maybe like an
underrepresented piece of acting advice
that um
even in auditions right I'd be
interested to see your take on this is
like
it can be better from my understanding
to just commit to a choice even if it's
the wrong one because then at least you
are giving a convincing performance of
something
even if it's incorrect
that's that's entirely correct I I think
it's
it's one of those scenarios where and
I've booked projects for my audition
wasn't what they were looking for
but the choice I made made them rethink
and reconsider the character and they
ended up liking that change or
conversely
my audition may not have been a right
for that character but they liked it for
something else that they had in the
project and that strong choice is what
made them think about it and it just
shows that you are able to with the once
again the very little context that often
you get with some of these auditions
where it's like you know 30 year old
born poor uh trying to save the world
from demons go and you're like okay
that's not a lot of contact super
relatable yeah you know so you have to
create that you have to create something
in that space that at least shows that
you know how to make something from
nothing because that already tells the
casting director that you can take a
little bit and run with it and they'd
much rather have somebody make a bold
choice that they can then correct and
alter than somebody that they have a
hard time getting anything out of yeah
so then to jump completely off of that
for anyone who is interested in getting
into voice acting
um what what are your biggest tips or
biggest things that you learned when it
comes to the audition process itself
uh how do you support
that's no that's that's it's an
interesting question because there's
there's different theories on what makes
a good audition I've been to workshops
in the past where I've heard conflicting
information from different casting
directions so part of it is you got to
make a choice I had one casting director
that was telling me Slade in the
character voice you know because they
want to know it right off the bat where
you are with this because if they're
listening to hundreds of auditions and
they're clicking through and you know
you're you don't sound right for it even
just the Slate sometimes they might just
skip over and keep going another one but
at the same time other casting directors
have said slate in your own voice
because if they don't like what you have
for the character they might find
something they like in your slate in
your natural speaking voice an
opportunity to present two voices that's
interesting exactly so you kind of I
can't say one's right or the other I
tend to slate I tend to slate in the
character voice unless it's a more
grounded realistic non-charactory
performance in which case I'll probably
State my natural voice to give them that
that hint of variety yeah sorry to know
what does slate mean
sorry the Slate yes the Slate is when
you state your name at the beginning of
an audition and sometimes they make you
say if you're sag
correct yeah you see if you're sag some
people have you say what your agency
you're with
some people say wait here to say what
character you're reading for which is
more common than not and some say
specifically just say your name and
nothing else you kind of make sure you
read the emails of the audition too
because some people have very specific
instructions on how they want the audio
delivered and you might you might [ __ ]
it up if you don't read it right sure
because yeah just following instruction
is a big part of getting a job too even
if your voice is great they're like well
you didn't follow the instructions
through that definitely post on a few uh
resumes in my time at IGN where people's
cover letters had typos and we were like
listen we're hiring you as a journalist
as good as all the rest of this was if I
have to proofread your cover letter
we're all in for a bad time a little bit
of a problem already a little bit of a
work issue there yeah so so there's
definitely conflicting advice so I guess
all you can really speak to is like what
you feel is right or what speaks to you
but like are there are there definitely
things that you feel like you would
recommend to people who are just new to
getting into the audition process
yes uh or for one cold reading is so
important to just voice over in general
because often you don't get the script
in advance often you don't have the time
and the opportunity to research and and
read all the material before you go into
the booth so a lot often you're just
interpreting the moment you see it it's
a lot of like oh there's a line on the
screen director comes over the mic and
is like all right I need an A and A B
take and go and you just have to roll
with it so taking dialogue taking scenes
from comic books and graphic novels are
great references whether it's just quick
snippy dialogue don't read it in advance
just pick it up to something you're
unfamiliar with and then perform the
dialogue in that scene record yourself
doing it listen back to it and be like
oh how do I want to tweet
comic books a really good example
because you're right it is like really
small chunks of dialogue that have
action that they often don't say yeah
that's a really good piece of advice hmm
you did it I did it another thing I
would I would I think is is really
important advice is
bringing the performance to life is more
than just reading the words on the
audition
meaning if you can just read the
dialogue that's great and everyone can
read the dialogue but consider in your
mind what physicality the character is
going through as they're doing the scene
if it says in the in the in the dial in
the the script you have that they sit
down in a chair to confront somebody
maybe consider between the lines giving
the vocalization of them sitting down in
a chair as opposed to going like hey we
need to talk you can go hey we need to
talk just that little bit of physicality
a person listening begins to hear the
movement begins to hear like it's a
living space if you think a character
might jump onto a table have them go
like
that's what I was thinking you know you
can put these little physical movements
these little pauses these little beat
size and reactionary things that aren't
written in the dialogue but that just
kind of give it a living breathing sense
to it especially when it comes to
animation in cartoons yeah you know if
you just read a cartoon character saying
their dialogue that's great but cartoons
are very well animated and so you want
to find moments and beats where they can
like react and like well I can stumble
over the dialogue or they can run up to
somebody like what's going on you know a
point to inspire a director too they
could hear that and be like oh I want to
animate this like that that's a really
exact good point so like you know
consider what sort of physicality exists
outside of what's written on the page
and if there is something written on the
page honor that with some sort of
physicality to the performance as well
don't be afraid to add beats especially
if it's a a naturalized performance
they're looking for something that feels
more cinematic and more grounded you can
take a moment to
think about things if your character is
contemplative maybe they
uh maybe they just need to think about
it for a second you know
fun to watch
is so fun we're all a little crazy well
it's absolutely true you're all Bonkers
100 but it's very entertaining
swap characters like that's really cool
so then you know you've got years and
years of experience now and you've done
a lot of characters what's a challenge
that you still feel like you face every
day because I'm sure you're not now just
subtly Challenge free
no no uh new challenges uh come all the
time both the the range of characters
that you have can adjust with age right
you know I've I'm doing many many years
of military shouts and Call of Duty
games and bestial Orcs And monster
voices which I really enjoy I've noticed
over the years my higher range is slowly
Vanishing and uh some of the characters
and younger sounding things I I used to
be able to do on that range begin to
just vanish Into The Ether like a Thanos
snap so you uh you'll learn that as a
unique challenge yeah um
I will say also
just the physical exertion that it takes
especially in video games the the sheer
volume of combat and combat Centric
dialogue that is required for games to
feel
real to feel dangerous to feel like
there is threat around you takes a lot
of effort energy and honestly uh trauma
to your vocal cords there's a lot of
discussion for many years uh with the
union and with you know Publishers and
developers of video games to ensure a
safer environment for voice actors
because a lot of us have taken serious
physical damage to our vocal cords uh
permanent in some cases and so uh and
that's gotten a lot better than it used
to be I will say like it's a very
noticeable difference in the industry
over the past 10 years which is
wonderful but it doesn't mean it's less
of a challenge to go into
a particular game project and see the
sheer scale of high intensity textured
growling yells they need you know 100
lines in a row of and you're just like
okay this is this is going to take me
out for the next couple days you know
what do you want to do to prepare for
that
make sure that I don't have anything in
the morning or before that session
that's too strenuous
um warm-up exercises uh like singing
exercises things that can get you into a
state where you're not just running in
cold and then battering your vocal cords
uh having a lot of tea a lot of things
that can help uh coat and soothe the
throat and not being afraid to take
breaks if you feel yourself reaching a
threshold tell the directors tell the
producers they're more than anything
waiting for you to do so because they
can they can't gauge where you are only
you can gauge your comfort and I know
especially if you're newer to the
industry because I've been there myself
as well where you're like I'm trying to
show off I can do this all day I don't
want to ever I want to show them that
I'm a professional and I can take it
honestly
you're just gonna hurt yourself yeah and
what what little bit has been going well
that guy was pretty good at that you'll
lose when all of a sudden the last hour
of the session you can't well the next
day the character yeah
yeah know your limits are certainly a
good thing to figure out which I yeah it
sounds scary when it comes to your voice
like do you ever leave a session
horse
yes yes often you have to go home and
Throat Coat Throat Coat teasing honey
yeah um Ninja on pepakoa which is a uh I
have some of that in my cupboard yep for
those who don't know it's a like a a la
quat uh like a thick sugary syrup that
helps coat the throat that's been a
lifesaver funny the amount of voice
actors who use it that nobody else knows
what it is like yeah it doesn't even
have any my label doesn't have any
English on it
it was after I did some I did some uh
multiplayer box for Gears which didn't
get used which I still think would be
very funny that they could in theory
release in a lot of PS like gears 5
multiplayer because I did it all hell oh
yes but the problem was again I'm not a
very good voice actor so part of it was
uh
the like stuff that was like
um you know when you're downed and gears
the character would ask to be picked up
like if you like pick me up or whatever
they kept making fun of me because I
just sounded really sad they were like
it's still a battlefield you sound so
sad and I was like I don't know what
else to do so I guess I'm like please
help like they're like you just sound
like you're crying I was like it'd be
very dramatic yeah yeah like even
soldiers have to really assess actually
yeah I just for some reason kept
sounding sad but that does exist uh the
Coalition they have it they have my
gears 5 multiplayer pack it's out there
but I use a lot of thrip code after that
yeah yeah no joke it was tough
I remember it was actually in one of the
one of the shadow of War Games things
maybe Shadow of Mordor the first one in
which I was one of the many orc voices
that any of the various Orcs And you
know trolls you could encounter in the
game have and I remember recording the
first like two hours of my first session
facial capture in the booth and they're
like all right cool so these uh you're
you're in battle you're screaming at the
top of your lungs you're charging into
the enemy and you're threatening them
and I'm gonna turn my gain here to give
an example it's like
you stupid talk I'm gonna skin you right
now
and so you have two hours of that let me
finish it I'm pouring sweat and my
throat's a little raw we're taking a
break and we come back in and the
writer's like all right cool so that was
like the low level barks now we're going
to take it to the medium level I'm like
what
you know and sometimes that that happens
and so you really have to know your
limits and you have to be willing to
step in and be like hey I know I've only
been doing this for 20 25 minutes after
the last break but I really need to give
myself a rest and 99 of the time they'll
be like of course please we'll take a
minute somebody says no you don't want
to work with them exactly that one
percent don't don't work with them again
do you feel do you feel like saying
physically
I think it doesn't hurt I don't think
it's absolutely necessary you know I
don't want to judge people's Lifestyles
and such but uh for me I think it helps
especially if you're doing performance
capture because it is a very physical
activity and a lot of things will be
asked of you in those you know scenarios
but I think also I mean a lot of times
voiceover is its own physical activity
or abdominals like what should you do
your orc there it was like that's that's
a lot of your body that's like going
tensing into making that performance a
reality I feel like it's people probably
get like sore muscles afterwards oh yeah
oh yeah yeah it's a it's a whole
especially when you're doing like combat
sounds impact pain sounds that's all
based inside your core and just tensing
different muscles and exertions so I
think it it is its own workout but uh
being physically fit does help because
it just helps your stamina uh it helps
you remain energetic over a long period
of time through physical activity
especially in projects that are
physically demanding so it definitely
helps I don't think it's necessary but I
think it definitely helps probably
applies to everything in life to be
honest kind of work out it's good for
your heart
[Laughter]
um on top of that because I think it's
an interesting question to ask what is
something that you think's helped you in
your career that is not directly related
to acting whether it's like consuming
other types of media or like like a
great example I got I do a writing
podcast and a person gave a piece of
advice recently that was make sure that
you work a job that isn't just being a
writer it's hard for people to relate to
you and your experiences if you've been
a writer your whole life go work at
McDonald's go work at a shoe store like
have regular human experiences so that
when you're writing your retail work a
character that you might have to write
one day you're at least you have
something believable to draw from and I
found that to be a really interesting
unexpected piece of advice that I
definitely would think brings true is
there anything like acting that that you
would think like one thing that helps
you that isn't
taught in University or isn't related to
the study of acting
well I mean you know just to go off what
you were saying first off that's awesome
advice and I agree with that even as a
performer as well
um I spent many years well the good news
is if you're going to become a
professional actor full-time you'll be
working a lot about a job that's true
you may be bartending maybe a waitress
it happens I spent many years as a
barista at a Barnes Noble Cafe I worked
for a temp agency and was like packing
shelves and warehouses I was putting
paperwork reports in for environmental
agencies like you it's good to get that
life experience and perspective too yeah
um but for I mean the nerdiest advice I
can give and because that's it
play role-playing games like tabletop
role-playing games I will say
my my confidence to get into voiceover I
would not have had if I hadn't spent so
many years dungeon mastering for my d d
games at home it was through creating
these worlds and inhabiting these
different characters and giving them
varying dialects and personalities and
living within a character that I created
where I wrote down their their fears and
their desires and having to engage my
players in a very immediate improvised
space right didn't know what was going
to happen next and then reacting to what
their choices are and living in that
space a lot of that skill set and a lot
of those experiences ended up
transitioning really well into my acting
career
um not to mention I got to build an
entire toolbox of voices and dialects
and personalities and characters for
voiceover that began as non-player
characters in my home d d games like
there are many characters that I played
in video games that have a bloodline to
campaigns that I ran at home 10 15 years
ago so uh and even if you if you don't
play for a long time there's something
about that wonderful immediacy that
creative space with other people at the
table uh where you just kind of let your
imagination take over you put trust in
the other people across from you and it
doesn't happen immediately necessarily
for some people it could take a little
bit of time once your comfort kicks in
but there is a there's a sparkling
moment when you get it when you give
yourself into this imaginary funds this
joyful space and just kind of Let
Yourself Go and live as this character
and react with other people in the same
space that it it just comes to life and
that sort of joy that spark is something
that you should Chase in the booth when
you're recording as well when you're in
a good pocket as a performer when you're
working well with the the directors and
the producer into
to get into that comfortable headspace
of the character you're performing to
where you find that that realness that
that kind of
impulsiveness that immediacy and then
when you see the dialogue and you've
been practicing your cold reading the
two come together to create an immediate
honest performance so be a nerd play a
tabletop
about uh voice acting oh I can speak to
his video games obviously but um is how
much work you do have to contribute to
crafting the character as well of course
somebody's already written a bio the
artists have already made the art they
already have written the dialogue in a
lot of cases but that stuff can shift
the minute that the right actor is cost
and and you become just the
collaborative effort of you know 20 50
people if you include all the animation
programs as well it's a lot of people
just to make this one character work and
you do have to be a part of that it's
not passive you can't just show up and
speak you really do have to like care
about who they are and get invested in
where they're going and how they move
and how they speak and I think that's
awesome and definitely probably d d
plays into that because it gives you the
sense of working with a team
it's called it's collaborative
creativity it is one of the joys I I
find in what we get to do with critical
role sometimes is bring in people who
are professional actors and performers
voice actors that we even met through
the industry who have not played any
role-playing games
and they're like kind of nervous and
like I don't I don't know uh I mean
you're you're my friend so I trust you
but I I hope I don't mess it up and then
once they get to that table once they
find that spark moment they just shine
and then when it's done when we go to a
break or we're done with our session
they come out like that was so much fun
this is what we do like this is this is
this is what we all have trained to do
but it's play and there's no pressure
and I'm like exactly that's why we love
to do it and so to that degree like
there there's a ironic ironically but
surprisingly for some people uh a lot of
crossover between the joy that you find
in voice over and the joy that you find
in tabletop games totally which came
first for you uh were you playing d d
and that made you want to get into
acting when you wanted to get into
acting before you started playing Dandy
uh I was playing d d before I got into
acting it was it was that was a super
introverted kid growing up I was that my
nickname is data in middle school you
know so I was helping people finish
their homework and I was just kind of
The Quiet nerd kid in the corner
watching anime with all my other ESL
friends
um they were getting me into Dragon Ball
and nobody else is into it but it was uh
it was
uh it was a scenario where through
playing role-playing games I began to
find a confidence to even try and
perform I would never have thought about
it you know I want to become an animator
uh be behind the scenes and it was
through for role-playing games that I
found that confidence and then
eventually got into theater in high
school and then the two kind of
dovetailed together and just kept
feeding each other and at the same time
I'm a huge Video Game Nerd and huge
anime nerd and saw his voiceover began
to grow as a facet of the industry I was
like oh man it'd be kind of fun to to
try that out see I doubt it'll ever work
out but you know at least I can give it
a shot and try and it was definitely a
lot of years of
small 50 background you know cop number
three in this project or whatever and uh
just eventually hitting the pavement
hard but yeah I it was my passion for
role-playing games that eventually led
into the confidence to begin to try for
performing as a career that's awesome
yeah I guess that's probably also like
people who struggle with social skills I
was also a very introverted quiet kid I
used drawing so I would just draw at
school and then people would talk to me
that's the only way like friends oh so I
would just draw and then someone'd be
like what's your drawing and it'd be
like finally even interact hell yeah I
did that for years but yeah I mean role
playing could probably help you build
confident social skills all that stuff
too there's definitely a lot of benefits
there yeah so I'm sure people have asked
you this a million times but because I
think people have very different answers
and it's always helpful for people to
hear who maybe haven't heard your story
before how did you actually get started
in acting like what what was the pathway
or what was your first leap like how did
you get work I guess is my question got
you my very very first gig was through
happenstance
um my father was an audio engineer in
the industry not for video games or
anything but he just did a lot of it was
called emini laybacks which means
whenever a a film would go towards its
final element's production or be going
into the foreign language Market he had
to lay down the music and effects that's
what m e stands for and so you have to
lay down the music and effects tracks
over the foreign dub or over the
existing kind of standard audio track
and make sure that all lines up and send
it off to the uh the studio mastering
pretty much yeah like final stage
masterings like that
um and one of their clients was a
company that was doing anime at the time
and the guy who is for one project my
dad was doing m e for the producer was
present and the producer was also a
musician my father and was also a
musician and so they've kind of bonded
over that they started doing little Jam
sessions in the weekend then my dad
started doing background characters
because my dad raised me on Warner
Brothers cartoons and Tech Savory
cartoons and doing character voices and
you know I grew up loving Mel Blanc
because my father raised me on Looney
Tunes
um so my dad started doing little
background voices and he was like hey
check it out your dad's doing cartoon
stuff I'm like that's so cool and then
one day he's like I'm going in to do
some background voices on this anime for
50 bucks an hour uh you want to come
with me and I'm like hell yeah so I came
in and watched him do the first half and
then I was talking to the director his
name was Joe ramersa and uh at the break
they're all doing a little cigarette
break and he's like you know what why
don't you come in and we'll have you do
a few more voices and like you seem to
be into this you know but make your day
to like how old were you
I was uh I would have been probably 18.
that's so cool what a cool opportunity
it was it was really freaking cool and
it was like three lines was like Hey you
know we're like where's he going you
know all that the little background
Wallace that was important stuff it is
it really is uh but you know it's it's
where it's where a lot of people cut
your teeth yeah and for some people
where you make a lot of money if you're
in one of those Loop groups for like
Warner Brothers oh yeah I have friends
who are just full-time lupus I didn't
even know that was a thing until I met
somebody who does it full time but
basically like uh you can explain it
better than me what would a full-time
Looper be
for any of them any Film Production that
happens they can't have background
voices uh mixing in with main character
dialogues when you see party scenes
group scenes anything that has some sort
of ambient conversation or you know
vocal elements in the background all the
background actors are quiet they're
silent they're just mouthing it Loop
groups then fill that space By by
filling in these dialogue pieces and
people who are really good at it they go
they work in these professional Studios
and they're very tight-knit groups that
like someone has to die
because they some of these people work
for Warner Brothers and do all the
Warner Brothers film properties and they
make Bank yeah I didn't even know it was
a thing and you can Almost Do It full
time yeah residuals man because it would
stack so much
yeah because unlike an actor who does
like one part on this one film they're
doing like every Warner Brothers film
that's in the pipelines they get
residuals on every film that goes out
there it's like one of the best kept
secrets of the industry and also it's
like a cabal it's like a full-on like
dark Subterranean Cult of the voice over
industry and I'm just like hey respect
to y'all I'm gonna you're crazy
I went in for an audition for one of
those like I guess they had an opening
and I went and met with her name was uh
Barbara Harris who has been like she's
like the queen of the Warner Brothers uh
uh loop group scene and so my agent was
like you have to go to this this is an
opportunity I'm like sure I'll go and I
go and show up to the Warner Brothers
lot and meet her and she's very nice up
front and then she gets very intense and
she's like okay so tell me about your
background your history I'm like okay
well I started finish like all right
cool now you're texting all right well
you know I was just sort of growing up
here in high school and she was like all
right cool now you're English
and of course you know I was trying to
make my teachers like all right cool now
you're you know Jamaican I'm like oh
they just this is getting weird
and and then she she brings me into the
room to do some looping with the actual
group and as soon as I walk in like all
eyes turn to me like like some sort of
hive mind like some sort of horror film
sequence like uh it was intense uh I did
of course did not get it and I'm kind of
happy because uh it was a bit much for
me but but that was a they're a very
tight-knit community and they make a
decent amount of money kind of holding
it down so good for them respect to them
also I thankless job just like UA it's
like super important you can't have
scenes that have just no people talking
in the background but they don't get the
shout outs like it's just so many so
many people working on Creative fields
yeah it's an odd spectrum of people in
the industry
um but uh I guess to finish the finish
that story that was kind of my my first
gig uh on that one and they stopped
calling my dad and started calling me
back instead take that Dad yeah he was
like I'd be angry if it was anybody else
uh but but it was like I'd come in and
do wall of voices once every year once
every six months for 50 bucks you know
it was it was it was just enough to wet
my appetite
to make me consider it as a real
possibility down the road so it was
it wasn't a career as a writer was the
same I started volunteer and then I was
maybe getting thirty dollars once every
month to write something and I was like
maybe I could do this full-time one day
but it still took yeah five years before
I made any livable wage
well and and to that point like I see a
lot of people that come to this town or
any major like performance-based you
know industry town uh going I give
myself six months and I'm out and I'm
like that's not gonna work like it's you
have to love it enough to be willing to
trudge through the rejection for a long
time you may get lucky and it'll come
sooner but like
there are my friend Darren DePaul who is
an incredible performer he's the voice
uh of his well if you look up his stuff
he's everywhere I met him doing Orcs And
Warcraft and he's he's the voice of uh
uh what's this in in Doom he's like the
AI robot that oh what is that kind of
the villain yes
he's Reinhardt in OverWatch
Doom AI
it's Doom 2016. what is his name yeah
yeah it's killing me it's killing me
no it's giving me Oh weird
she's got a pop-up on the video from my
twitch chat let me turn that off
um it's giving me I the first result for
Doom AI robot 2016 is scientists teach
machines to hunt and kill humans what
that's not what I was searching for I've
completely forgot what his name is Vega
Vega that's it v-eg-a
I think it's this way we are yes
hello I am Vega the sentient
intelligence assigned to Moz that's
Samuel Hayden that's what it is someone
above it oh okay
yeah he's like the dude he was once
living and now he's a robot anyway look
up Darren DePaul he's done a billion
things and you'll never recognize he's
he just has this deep resonant voice he
does monsters screams and and just I
mean like Reinhardt you know big German
voice he's he's a big voice he's also
this this delightful uh you know vest
wearing uh like completely unassuming
Uncle of a figure he he just he just
looks like this sweet accountant you'd
see in like a like a 1990s film and he
has this huge voice but he was you know
doing community theater and doing some
stuff in New York for a long time he
didn't start getting into voiceover
until he was in his late 50s
and and he'd been doing it for a long
time and then eventually he just kept
trudging for it met the right person got
on the right project in his career
exploded so you never know when the
opportunity will arise that could really
lead to success so if it's something
you're really passionate about something
you really want to get into you kind of
have to be in it for the long haul
definitely
you know I'm a big proponent of trying
something and failing than not trying
and always you know living with the
regret that you never gave it the chance
yeah and knowing limits and boundaries
is also good because sometimes you might
reach your point where you're like I'm
maybe this isn't for me or maybe you
find another passion that excites you
more and has more opportunity that
direction and led you there but you you
find your own path that's great too but
you can't go in there knowing I'll give
it a little shot and then I'll Just
Bounce out at the first sign of any sort
of you know rejection because I will
tell you most of your job as a voice
actor is rejection yeah actors have to
deal with a lot of rejection and
sometimes very impolite rejection like
you can play a soul into something and
submit it and not even hear back which
seems very rude to me 95 of the time you
don't hear back which is deal with that
as a human
uh that's actually there's another good
point of voice over advice uh when you
finish an audition Let It Go
you you cannot hang on to the
possibility uh because it'll eat you
alive yeah
um and you know that you won't hear
about it so for me that the healthier
perspective is to get excited for the
audition do the job in the room do the
best you can and then once you submit it
forget about it and then focus on the
next opportunity yeah that way if it
doesn't come you've already you've
already let it go yeah if it does come
it's a wonderful surprise and I will say
I only had one project this past like
year year and a half that I held on to
and it was something that was very
personal to me and I
put everything into this audition and
then didn't hear anything back for a
long time was like it was like the one
project I was like
yeah
so uh it's like you know don't don't put
yourself in that position to to to
to just linger in the space of regret or
not knowing because and there also been
projects that I've auditioned for and
I'll say like commonly you usually hear
back within a month or two after an
audition sometime sooner uh depending on
what stage and production they are and
they're in projects at audition four and
then found out I booked it a year and a
half later they were just they were like
looking for it way earlier in the in the
production cycle and they didn't need
you until two years of development had
gone by wow so you never know when it
might come back yeah as well so another
reason to hold on to it because you
don't hold on to it for two years that's
a lot of holding on to things that's a
lot of stress
um to jump back to your story so you
were you were getting occasional jobs
fifty dollars here and there how did you
get beyond that point
I I began doing like bigger Parts here
and there like little video game bits
um occasionally like a bigger meteor
piece and a like on an Ace Combat game
where I was kind of the narrator for it
and that felt really cool were you
finding those jobs through networking or
oh I was finding those jobs through the
I was finding those through auditions
for the company that I started doing
anime background gotcha okay
and then I would meet other people while
I was doing early Game Dev you know with
some of the developers and stuff yeah
um I'd be like hey so well if you're
ever casting anything and they'd be like
all right cool I don't know who you are
everyone says that shut up weird guy of
course yeah exactly yeah and I can't
totally get that I probably was breaking
protein
tell people you want to walk I think
it's a great idea people are always
afraid like you have to tell people that
you want to do things otherwise how's
anyone going to know to help you exactly
but to do it respectfully because I've
I've had people come up to me that have
been very respectful about it I'm like
hell yeah you know what I'll listen to
your stuff maybe I'll pass it on to
somebody and people have been very
disrespectful about it I'm like bye it
doesn't matter how good you are if you
suck to work with nobody wants to work
with you exactly the I mean that's
actually a very good point especially in
this industry voice over more than a lot
of other facets of the industry I think
is very supportive very positive and the
majority of the people that work in this
space are wonderful people I can't tell
you how many times I've been in
auditions or friends of mine been in
auditions for uh something and we
finished the audition and told the
director like I don't think I'm right
for this part but I know somebody who I
think would be great for it and we
recommend each other for things and then
you get excited when they book it yep
um right is doing the same thing 100
it's like I'm I can't write this but I
know someone who can who's available
right now and then you end up just like
making a network of more and more people
and nothing is quite as nice as seeing
people that you know have worked on that
are in your circle or outside of your
circle succeed it's great it always
feels good completely agree and to that
point there are a lot of talented people
in these spaces so you can be really
talented
and an [ __ ] yeah
and the people are just going to pick
the other talented people that aren't
yeah because they can make that choice
there are a lot of things to pick from
it rarely rarely does an [ __ ] get
through and usually they make it they
the industry knows pretty quickly yeah
so like you know be kind be respectful
be appreciative and do the work that's
kind of the the base of it but to finish
your earlier question uh I eventually
reached a point I think it was like 2008
I was working for Infinity Ward on
Modern Warfare
uh on the dev side of things and
wonderful people there are a lot of
friends to this day you also worked on
cod4
I did I worked on Call of Duty 2 and
then the first Modern Warfare no wait
a bunch of my friends there went to
respawn and then we all keep contact
there and hang out and stuff so like
yeah
a lot of good people there love to
respawn um they're still an Infinity
Ward from the back day too like oh yeah
you've endured it all oh yeah uh can't
be easy
but uh but I just reached a point where
I was like I
I wanted to give this a real shot I
don't want to live with the regret of
never really putting the effort and
energy into it so I I saved up for a
while kind of like built a little next
egg where I could downsize my life I
quit my job at Infinity Ward
um and then just
deeply downsized my my lifestyle and
then began to push for auditions began
to go to workshops begin to network and
just kind of train myself and better
myself and meet people and and put
myself out there and it wasn't immediate
it took a number of years of
occasionally getting a gig here and
there meeting people that would bring me
in for stuff and then I begin to book a
little more uh there was actually one
project I worked on I think it was
called
it's like it's some something something
the Argonauts was like a Jason the
Argonauts type game for Xbox that came
out in like the late 2000s but a friend
of mine who was working at a Dev studio
in Pasadena texted me and was like hey
they're doing auditions for the game
we're working on right now do you want
me to put you on the list and I was like
yes please okay cool all right put me on
the list so I show up this audition I
read for it directors really intense but
good and I never met them before
and like cool happy in the booth uh I do
the audition and they're like okay cool
thank you for that also could you read
for this as well make sure I'll do that
finish that and then she looks at the
list and goes you didn't you didn't put
down your agency here because there's a
little list for putting down what agency
you're with and I left it blank because
I didn't have one I was like I don't
I don't have an agent oh we're going to
change that oh she immediately
recommended me to the agent I've had all
this time that's awesome
and also Taft heart lead me on that
project as one of the villains that I
read for which then got me into the into
sag and then she's been her name is
Chris Zimmerman she directed all the
metal gear games she directed the
Spider-Man game uh that came out
recently uh she's an incredible voice
director and I I'm I owe a lot of my
career to her honestly just taking a
chance on me but once again it's being
at the right place at the right time and
networking with people that believe in
you so that that person who's a friend
of mine knew
that this opportunity would arise that
they could reach out to me to pull me in
if I missed that audition if I hadn't
made that friend I would never been
brought in and met Chris and I wouldn't
have had my agent and who knows what
weird career path I would have spun off
to at that point and also being open to
help like I I kind of mentioned this
before but I think that's also a huge
thing is like there are a lot of people
who
um when they're first starting out
especially when you just leave school
and you've got straight A's and you feel
like you're ready to go and you don't
want to accept help and that could be a
really hard huddle for I think a lot of
young people to get over to is like you
have to be willing to like let people
edit you let people give you feedback
take feedback and criticism well which
is really hard especially if you're in a
bad mood it can be really hard to take
criticism uh definitely a learn skill
and also just like let people give you
opportunities and push you in the right
direction and
help people back
yeah and actually that and to play off
of that too direction is not criticism
right uh when a director is telling you
in the booth whether it be an audition
or an actual professional gig you might
give your all to Performance and like
okay uh not like that or if if they
shouldn't say not like that but some
some technically like whatever the [ __ ]
that was some directors that are still
good directors can be very blunt and you
just have to learn to not take it
personally so you're collaborating yeah
exactly you're doing the best you can to
work together and bring make it the best
it can be and so you you can't view uh
Direction and feedback from the director
as criticism they have more context than
you do yeah you know you only know what
you've been given on this project they
may have been directing it for months or
even years at this point and they need a
very specific thing to fit in the
overall tapestry and so there and
they're rooting for you they wouldn't
have cast you and put through all the
time and energy energy and effort money
of bringing you into here if they didn't
if they weren't pulling for you to make
their job easier and hopefully get home
early like they want you to they want
you to succeed so know that they're in
your corner and any direction any
feedback any changes or tweaks they're
doing is is that collaboration don't
take it personally
and that's really important and that you
know I I I think
I've heard people I mean there are some
directors that are dicks out there and
you know you just kind of deal with it
and go on and uh no it might bring it up
with other voice actors like if you had
a bad experience with this director like
okay cool we'll be like okay well I'm
not alone in that but but it's even
that's rare too like generally I think
most directors in this industry are that
I've worked with have been very very
kind and very down for the cause which
is great how do you deal with
um insecurity I was gonna say surely you
don't have any anymore but you're still
a human
how do you deal with like hiding
insecurity from coming out through
acting
as a person who's riddled with
insecurity in many stages I can tell you
uh I'm figuring it out therapy therapy
um uh I
a lot of it just comes through practice
uh
practice practice practice makes it
become a reflexive Instinct than a scary
thing yeah like like the more energy and
effort and the more weight that you put
onto it the more those insecurities will
begin to seep in and take over the more
rehearsal the more practice the more
just study you do and repetition for
your skill in your craft the more you
don't have to think about those things
you just kind of let it take over the
more natural it becomes in that space
and the insecurities wash away because
instead of focusing on your acting
you're just present and letting it come
out of you and that you know some people
might have and I've seen some people
like young people that are instinctually
just that's where they live and that's
great but for for a lot of people out
there that don't have that it is a skill
it is a trained skill that you can
develop through repetition that you can
develop through focus and training over
time I listen to myself my early years
of my career and I cringe so hard at how
I sound in my performances and I could
hear those insecurities in my
performance because I'm I'm desperately
trying trying to not let these people
down who took a chance on me and not
wanting to have these projects come out
and have all the feedback be terrible
and have the internet just destroy me
for my you know my journeyman
experiences in this industry uh but only
through kind of pushing beyond that
boundary and just focusing on the work
and repetition can you eventually let go
of that tension and that leaves very
little space for the insecurities to
take over that's a great piece of advice
I'm going to ask you one more question
before I let you go hardest question of
the evening oh what'd you go who's your
favorite actor and why
of all time Eva alive or dead
I said I I warned you I told you it
would be tough
oh that's so tough
I
I asked uh Elias to fix this the same
question and he was like oh uh uh like I
think I saw someone the other day
um
like a lot of the actors that I asked
just say I don't know well I don't have
one and I'm like that's not fair you
have to have somebody that just inspires
you somebody you love in a certain scene
in a certain movie it's got to be
someone
I mean there are actors that I love
um but I'd say like and it sounds like
such a hackneyed voice over choice
but I I I did a book report on Mel blank
in fourth grade because I loved his work
in Looney Tunes I guess as a as a person
that brought cartoon characters to life
with his voice learning about his his
life his trials and tribulations like
how he came up through that scene and
how he's such a an icon still to this
day uh for voice over like I
there are many performers who I love and
I love them in certain roles and I love
certain films but it's rare that there's
an individual like him that I can look
back and see a bloodline throughout my
entire life that I followed his work
been inspired by his work and now to see
you know
people carry on that that joy and and
expand on the things that he did and
live up to that is is incredible that's
a great answer one of my favorite people
to ever exist is Carl Sagan sort of for
a similar reason just a human who was
very smart in a very specific way but
used that intelligence to educate people
and I feel like
that's such a good human you could have
just kept that to yourself and made a
bunch of money but you dedicated so much
of your life to making sure that
everybody else understood this thing you
were an expert at me never stopped being
inspired by Carl Sagan that's a great
choice in particular he just sort of
leaves an important mark on many lives
he's here in the room right now welcome
in call oh bless him I I to this day
like if if I if I wanted to pick me up
there's I think something called
Symphony of Science yeah that does these
incredible bits of music using clips of
Carl Sagan from the original Cosmos and
just assuming about his voice when it's
auto-tuned it's just such a such a
calming experience
uh Clips while DJing before I love that
it's a good time um all right thank you
so much for chatting with me today again
I'm sure we could chat forever this is
wonderful I I love your enthusiasm it's
always just exciting to see somebody
who's a passionate talk about stuff
they're passionate about so thank you
thank you for having me around this is
this is this the [ __ ] I love so oh yeah
uh what are you up to right now where
can people find you do you have anything
you want to you want to promote
uh you can find me on Twitter at Matthew
Mercer or Instagram at Matthew mercervio
for those who do the social media thing
uh uh also you can find us on Twitch
most Thursdays uh me and a bunch of
other fantastic voice actors like Laura
Bailey Travis Willingham Lima Brian Sam
Regal Marisha Ray tells jaffee and
Ashley Johnson playing Dungeons and
Dragons for critical role at 7 pm
Pacific cool thank you so much and also
Legend of ox Machina on uh Prime video
go check out our cartoon season three
all righty thank you all for watching
I'll see you next time bye thanks
everybody bye
[Music]
thank you
[Music]